[Music]
what a moment are you loving this time
right now Awards recognition the number
one movie in the world how does it feel
it feels amazing I love you know I love
being an actor I love the thrill of
playing different characters so when it
all happens to be occurring at the same
moment it's beautiful
et spoke with Laura Dern at the LA
premiere of her new film downsizing but
it's not the only project that has fans
buzzing with burning questions Jeff
Goldblum he's going to come back in
Jurassic Park could we see you you've
said before you're up for it yeah I mean
I love Ellie Sattler I just want to see
her just drag that leg feminist we need
we need her back honey mommy is getting
very upset big little lies too I mean
you're you're in right you're confirmed
I don't know if I'm confirmed but I know
we all want to be there and I'm sure we
have a deep plan about that how was it
to get nominated for the show and see
the Awards recognition it got again just
gorgeous and I mean I think it speaks to
the kind of storytelling people want to
see and hopefully everybody's catching
up now to say oh yeah this is what
audiences are longing for Reese and I
took our kids to an amusement park and a
bunch of frat boys kind of came up to us
and their early 20s on spring break and
we're like oh my god big little eyes is
our favorite show we're like wait a
minute it's not this is universal
there's a lot of a lot of different
audiences interested in storytelling
that happens to be female characters and
so may there be much much more
and more of you and I sure hope so
[Music]
you
[Music]